solution proposée par les rapporteurs du
plan faire glisser l'âge de la retraite
progressivement de 60 ans à 62 ans en
l'an 2010 ce qui maintiendrait le
rapport actuel entre le nombre de
retraités et le nombre d'actifs deuxième
solution cumulable avec la première un
nouveau calcul des pensions non plus sur
le salaire des dix meilleures années
comme aujourd'hui mais sur le salaire
moyen de toute la vie professionnelle ce
qui aboutirait bien sûr à une baisse
légère de la pension secundo si
l'assurance maladie indispensable jugent
les experts de maîtriser l'évolution des
dépenses de santé qui jusqu'à présent
ont bénéficié d'un degré de liberté
exceptionnel première solution réguler
le nombre de médecins en limitant le
nombre de diplômés à l'université
deuxième solution
développer les modes d'intervention de
l'état et des caisses d'assurance
maladie dans la mise sur le marché des
nouveaux médicaments souvent coûteux et
l'homologation des nouveaux matériels
pour l'hôpital les experts préconisent
la rue monge version des petits hôpitaux
en établissement pour personnes âgées
dépendantes
vers l'an 2000 en effet elles seront
cent mille plus 800 mille semi
dépendantes
aujourd'hui il n'existe que cinq cent
mille places pour les accueillir
enfin troisième dossier la famille cette
branche de la sécurité sociale
contrairement aux deux précédentes est
traditionnellement excédentaire les
experts préconisent d'utiliser cet
excédent pour développer des prestations
ciblées en direction des familles les
plus modestes